hello everyone welcome back to our
Channel if you are new here don't forget
to hit that subscribe button and the
bell icon so you won't miss our future
videos today we are diving into the
fascinating world of AI especially we
are talking about chat Tubidy a language
model developed by open AI whether you
are a developer a student a researcher
or just an AI Enthusiast this video will
provide you with some essential tips to
get started with chat GPD chat Jeopardy
is a powerful tool that uses machine
learning to generate human-like text
it's been trained on a diverse range of
internet text but it can also be
fine-tuned with your own data to perform
a variety of task so buckle up and
before that if you are one of the
aspiring Ai and ml enthusiasts looking
for online training and graduating from
the best universities for a professional
who only sits to switch careers in Ai
and machine learning by learning from
the experts and try giving a show to
Simply learns postgraduate program in Ai
and machine learning in collaboration
with Purdue University and IBM the
course link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete audio of the program being
offered so let's get started with the
top tips for beginners for using charge
APD and to get started you will need to
access the open AI API
so we'll start with the first trip that
is change your dashboard appearance so
for that we'll move to chat GPD and you
could change the desktop appearance for
Dash to Port appearance of charge
debating you can customize your
dashboard by going to settings and
choosing a new theme or layout so for
settings
you will go here and in general you can
just select the theme that is light you
can change it to dark system theme or
light theme so these are the options you
can use to change your dashboard
appearance so this can help you create a
more comfortable and personalized
working environment for example you can
change the color scheme and you can also
change the font size also and you can
generally change the font size by just
zooming in the window
and the second tip we have is switch on
beta features so we have moved back to
charge repeat and here you can see the
beta features so for that we'll go in
settings and data that is custom
instructions try a new feature that lets
you share anything you would like charge
gbd to consider closets responses so we
have switched on these beta features the
plugins try a version of chat chipity
that knows when and how to use
third-party plugins that you enable the
code interpreter that is a version of
child Tubidy that knows how to write and
execute python code and can work with
file uploads so asking for help with
data analysis image conversions or
editing a code file and these files not
persist Beyond a single session so these
are the plugins or the beta features
that we have turned on and we are using
them and in chat gvt4 gbt4 you could see
that is code interpreter beta and the
plugins beta they both are available for
us so this was the second tip that is
switch on the beta features and you can
use them that is you can toggle on beta
features to try out new and experimental
features if you like trying out new
features you can switch on beta features
there are experimental features that are
still being tested keep in mind that
they might not always work perfectly and
the next is change the tone of your
writing that is you can ask chat GPT can
you rewrite any sentence in a more
formal way so now we will ask a prompt
to check GPT that is can you rewrite
this in a more formal tone and what we
can ask is that could be hey how are you
okay so we will ask this so you could
see that the child CPT has changed the
tone of the sentence or the imperative
you were asking that is hey how are you
now greetings how do you find yourself
today so this is a more formal tone and
you can ask chargpt for more such
responses that is give me more such
responses
so you can change the tone of the
sentence that is you could give any
sentence or any imperative or any
language to chat GPT and you can ask for
any tone that could be emotional that
could be funny tone or that could be
sarcastic tone so chat Jeopardy would
reply with the particular tone
so this was our third tip and now moving
on we'll see the fourth tip that is use
chat GPT for quick learning so you can
ask can you explain the basics of
anything that could be the simple
biology Concepts the solar system and
you can use charge apt for quick
learning that is for instance you could
ask any prompt
that is here we will ask chargpt that
teach me
how to write
hello world in Python
so you can see that Jupiter responded
that is shown writing a hello world
program in Python is quite
straightforward due to python Simplicity
and here's how you can do it that is
print hello world and in this code it
has given you some sentences so you can
just read them and understand how the
code works that is print is a built-in
python function that outputs specified
information to the screen then the text
that is hello world that is an inverted
commas is a string which is a type of
data representing text then the
parenthesis that are used to include the
arguments of the function so when you
run this program it will give the output
of the text that is hello world to the
console so this is the fourth tip and
moving on now we have our fifth tip that
is view the plugin store so now chat GPT
has many plugins that is we will create
a new chat and in gbt4 you could just
click on plugins So currently no plugins
are enabled
and this is the plugin store so the
developers are developing plugins so you
could use them and be more productive
and add more features to the chat CPT so
you could see that is aipdf that is
super fast interactive chats with PDFs
of any site complete with page
references for fact checking ask your
PDF chat with PDF Expedia notable link
reader so these are the plugins that you
could use
and this comes with the gpt4 version
that is the paid version
so you could enable any plugin and you
can write any prompt and the chat jbt
will respond to it now moving on to the
next step
that is tip 6 use the web browsing
feature so with gpt4 and with the beta
versions you get a feature to search
with Bing or to browse with bank that is
not available for my account or for my
area so this is the new tip you can use
it if you have the paid version and if
you are accessible for the beta version
of browsing with pink so this was our
next step and moving on we will see our
seventh tip that is template eyes useful
prompts so you can ask can you create a
10 minute full body workout using some
kind of dumbbells or a barbell roll and
save this problem for future use you can
also templateize useful prompts for
instance you can also ask can you create
a menu or to do list and save this
prompt for future use so we'll see a
quick example that would be
creator
10 minute
full body workout and that would be
using so you could see that the chat GPT
has given us a templatized routine so as
a quick high intensity bowel workout
that you can complete in about 10
minutes that is bubble deadlifts and
bubble squats bubble overhead press
bubble Rose marble bench press so for
that you also need to have bench press
also and the notice remember the key to
this workout is intensity and form not
necessarily the paid used okay so this
is how you can templatize useful prompts
and moving on the next step we have is
summarize text that is you can paste a
long article and ask chat Jeopardy to
convert it or summarize in few sentences
for example you can paste a long arcade
article
so I will show you how we can do that we
will just search for
synchronous articles
so we'll
use any article just copy it and give
this to chat Jeopardy that is paste it
and ask it can you
summarize this article
five sentences
so you know that this prompt will just
summarize the whole article into five
sentences and this is the feature of
charge apt to summarize anything and in
a very concise manner and this was our
tap eight and moving on
the next tip we have is analyze your
writing pattern
that is can you you can ask chargpt can
you analyze my writing style and
generate a paragraph by making it that
is you can give it any text or chat that
you have done you can just copy that
chat and give that as a prompt to chat
GPT and you can then write a prompt that
can you analyze my writing style and
generate a paragraph by making it on any
topic so the chat Jeopardy will analyze
your writing pattern and will mimic your
style and you can also ask it to act as
a famous person like you can ask chargpt
to act like Elon Musk and give your
thoughts on AI
so here
we will ask strategypt that is
act as Elon Musk and give your thoughts
on here
so you could see that it has stated that
artificial intelligence was immense
potential for human advancement it's
eventually digital superintelligent and
can be on a human intelligence but it is
not saying that it can perfectly act as
Elon Musk or it can directly speak to
Elon Musk but you can provide a
perspective based on his public
statements on the topic of artificial
intelligence so the child CPT has
analyzed all its statements that are
present that is gpd4 has some browsing
features so it has analyzed all the
statements and on behalf of that it has
given us the result and now moving on to
the next step practice act as an
examiner so you can ask can you check
this essay for grammatical errors you
can ask it to check your project or even
grade your homework so as we have copy
pasted the article you can copy paste
your if you want to check your code or
debug your code you can just give way to
chat jpt and it will give you the
suggestions or it will point out some
matters and can give you a perfect code
or you can just ask him to get some
grammatical errors in your article or
essay so this was the 10th tip that is
act as an examiner and now the next is
formatted outputs so you can give any
data to chat jpt and ask him to format
this into tables and you can ask him to
add some columns to the tables that
would be Monday Tuesday Wednesday and
you can ask him to prepare to-do list or
something like that so you can format
your outputs chargpt will respond to
that so for that we'll just give it a
prompt with jpt that is
format the days of week in a table and
days put days in column so let's see so
you could see that it has given us and
it has given all the days in one column
so you have to correct your prompts and
rewrite your prompts and see what chat
Jeopardy is responding with those
problems so you have to be concise and
be conscious and just regenerative forms
so now moving on to and next step
that is tip number 12 let us generate to
do list you can say I need to do grocery
shopping finish a report and call my
friend today and can you create a to-do
list for me so chat GPT can create to-do
list just tell it what task you need to
complete and it will create a to-do list
for you you can just you just have to
give it a prompt and the next step we
have is explain it to a child so this is
you can ask can you explain how a rocket
Works to a five-year-old you can ask
chat Jeopardy to explain complex
conception simple terms just say explain
it to a child followed by the concept so
for example you can also ask that can
you explain quantum physics to a child
so we will just try this prompt
that is explained quantum physics
to a child
so this will give you
so you could see that the charge GPT has
given the answer that is absolutely
there's a very simple way to explain
quantum physics to a child and it has
given a Lego books example you can build
a castle a spaceship or whole city so
this is how you can use this prompt
that was the tip number 13 that is
explaining to child then the next step
we have is Shadow chat thread links so
after having a productive conversation
with charge everyday you can share this
conversation by clicking on the share
button and sending the generated link to
your colleagues this is a great way to
collaborate with others for instance if
you are working on a project with a team
you can share the link to a chat thread
so everyone can see the conversation and
contribute so I will show you how you
can do it that is this is the share
button share a chat and you can just
copy the link and send it to anyone and
you can collaborate with them and now
moving on to a next tip that is tip
number 15 let us export data to mail if
you want to export a chat you can click
on the export button and enter your
email address you will receive a copy of
the chat in your inbox this useful
feature is used if you want to save a
record of your conversation or if you
need to share the information with
someone who doesn't have access to
charity
so I will show you how you can do it so
simply you have to go here click on
settings and go to data controls and
here is your option that is export data
so just click on export confirm export
and the successfully exported data you
should receive an email shortly with
your data and now moving on we will see
another tip that is
organize your chat history
so you can organize your chat history
that is you can edit it and you can name
anything that is
tips for share jpd so this is how you
can organize your
chat history
and now moving on
now we'll see the next step that is go
minimalist
so what do you understand where
minimalist is you can just
close this sidebar so this is the
minimalist options here you can just use
the chat GPT here so in settings you can
choose a minimalist theme which will
remove any unnecessary elements from
your dashboard leaving only with
Essentials and if you prefer cleaner
look you can go minimalist and this
removes any unnecessary elements and you
can delete all your history that is in
settings you can find the delete all
history button clicking this will erase
all your previous chats and for privacy
reasons you might want to delete your
chat history you can do this by going to
a settings and selecting delete old
history so this was a tip number 18 that
is delete all your history
so we'll just go to settings data
controls and here we have chat history
and training that is turn on if you will
turn off it will just turn off and it
will also act as an incognito mode and
here you can clear all the chats this
will delete all the history
and the next step we have is describe
images and the Nexus summarize YouTube
videos
so this is available with beta features
of Bing that is you can just write
describe image
and paste any image link here so the
charge GPT will describe the image for
you and if you want to like know about
any YouTube video so you can just write
described YouTube video and then paste
the link and it will describe the
YouTube video for you and that is
available with the beta feature of
browsing with Bing and if that is
available with you
and currently that is not available with
me you can like if you if the feature is
available with you that is a better
feature you would able to see here that
was the beta feature and you can also go
into settings and data and check out if
the feature is available for you or not
so these were the tips and that's it
those are some of the ways you can
customize your charge APD experience
remember the key to mastering any new
tool is practice and experimentation so
don't be afraid to dive in and start
exploring what chat Deputy can do and if
you found this video helpful please give
it a thumbs up and share it with your
friends and before ending let's hear
from our Learners who have experienced
massive success in their careers hey
I'm Sharia Jaleel I live in Ontario
Canada I have been in I.T sector for the
past 20 years I recently took the
professional certificate program in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning the course has changed the way
I look at things and helped me back some
amazing freelance projects I started my
career in 1999 and over the years I have
worked with many companies my last tenor
was with IBM Canada my aim was to
restart my career and learn something
that would help accelerate my career
I thought artificial intelligence can
make me Future Ready
the course in artificial intelligence
and machine learning is provided by
simply learn in association with Purdue
University which is why I chose the
course I did not have high expectations
from online course but my experience was
simply awesome the quality of
interaction within the course was simply
amazing the course faculty was also very
experienced and knowledgeable
after the course my knowledge has grown
manifold I have immensely benefited from
Python and coding skills I am able to
get some new freelance projects also I
am planning to start an AI based startup
with my friend where I feel that the
learning from the course to be very
helpful I am really delighted and happy
in my free time I try to create
meaningful content on YouTube and I talk
about new technologies and what kind of
courses professionals should be taking
along with many other topic I definitely
recommend this course to everyone after
all when it comes to new skills to
advance your career there should be no
compromise you should always learn from
the band
[Music]
and thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next one staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign